hey it's a style I direct the series
earworm here on our video channel I
figured I'd come in dear the video lab
today and give you some fun music
related recommendations straight from my
brain to your YouTube feed or whatever
[Music]
so the very first recommendation I have
is a book called how listen to jazz by
ted gioia I read this right before I
started my jazz mini series everything
from Dixieland to jazz fusion ted gioia
has you covered and the perfect thing
about this book is that at the end of
each chapter ted gives you a playlist of
songs that he either references or he
thinks are really great examples of each
of the styles the second book i want to
recommend is called album cover album
and it is a giant heavy beautiful
picture book of album covers but instead
of them being organized by genre or
musical artists or time period they're
really organized by the style of the
album cover this one's like science
fiction comic style album covers
ears and butts artists artsy portraits
whenever I'm trying to come up with
earworm ideas I always open this book
and just try to like kind of immerse
myself in the visuals of music album
cover album highly recommend so I have
two more recommendations the first is a
video by Andrew Wong he's a really
awesome music youtuber and he did this
great short visual breakdown of how sine
waves work if you've always wanted to
understand how synthesized sound works
this is the perfect video for you the
second recommendation is very similar so
instead of a video it's an interactive
that the pudding did where they allow
you to sort of adjust the parameters of
a sine wave and hear exactly in
real-time how those adjustments actually
sound so the last thing I thought I
would do is just give you a little
teaser of what you can expect in earworm
season 2 I ordered a couple of albums
online and they came to me of course
packaged in boxes so I don't know which
albums are in these boxes but I figured
I'd open up and do like a gender-reveal
but for earworm episode let's just try
it out oh my god
this is gonna be impossible to open i
need keys
[Music]
we're going to talk about how this
12-inch single and the song on it
changed music thanks so much for
watching the next time I'm here I will
have probably published one or two
earworm episodes I'm so excited to share
behind-the-scenes extras for a one
season two so stay tuned bye